[Music]
in ride-or-die news here's what this is
submitted by what's new pussycat oh you
knew it you knew it what's new pussycat
what is that but who is the original
okay all right woman in Thailand is
standing by her man at whoa this is a
ridah guy as he suffers from a
disfiguring eye cancer
oh [ __ ] okay I know you would get cancer
in the eyes I think you can get cancer
anywhere oh really yeah there's nose eye
cancer is just like radioactive sales I
mean everything you're saying to see his
face it's real people don't know I was
uncontrolled growth that spreads okay
yeah there you go that sounds more like
it I mean also he did say it very
seriously and I believed it that's true
I think you could say anything with that
tone and it'll sound right it's when
they go crazy and they can't control
them so you know I didn't know that
there was hospitals for specific things
like I was looking to have a looking for
a general physician because I just never
go to the hospital but I'm like now that
I'm getting older I probably should I'm
here but check if they have my off too
but this airline but you know I like
when I'm 40 they gotta put a figure in
there make sure that it's okay yeah so I
went to there's like a place called City
of Hope and I try to set up doctor
appointment like oh this is for cancer
good you have cancer I was like
absolutely not I'm sorry to waste your
time I'm so embarrassed I Milwaukee for
myself
I didn't know I don't know they have
like specific Hospital for specific [ __ ]
no a Children's Hospital geriatric
hospital plastic surgeon you know what
actually I kind of did something similar
except I made it I actually made a
physician's appointment at an urgent
care and didn't know that the urgent
care I yes they said it was a doctor and
the doctor worked to that era to care so
I made a point with that doctor and I
came into the urgent care and they were
like you have an appointment yeah gonna
walk in like that's all I think about
doctors doctor man everybody got a mouth
to the butthole you could check it all
right
we're talking about this couple here
from Thailand so things are at teeth
tied oh yeah sorry I'm trying
yeah I am the people to is it is the
girl a Tina
I hate okay Spanish the Chinese they're
no Sita no Filipino he brought the a her
finger and coo coo that's it like a pair
like we need a pool like what do you
mean
so it has retinal blastoma which is
cancer like it starts in the retina
that's kind of weird bread which is the
back of the eye to the brain like
probably can because the red is about my
god there's a picture so here's what he
looked just kidding just scared me but
I'll still like what's in the way so
this is still before so they've been
together for three years
awesome and recently they she posted up
a photo of them celebrating the three
years and that went viral because she's
been standing by her man this is my
beginning
this is as it was progressively getting
worse oh ma how come they didn't put
like cat like drugs and stuff it's an
untreatable so you're just gonna die
horrible who was it possible oh my god I
like his pose he's posing yeah he lost a
lot of weight yeah he can't see and so
she just can you speak I'm not sure oh
my think if they just took out his
eyeballs he'll be fine
well they've done that a while ago yeah
well they're saying that I'm not
treatable and he's at the end stage I
cancer that's crazy cuz it doesn't even
look like human anymore like it looks it
looks like a cartoon character it looks
like Photoshop looks like emoji like I'm
trying to like like okay in my head
right now I get it and I'd be like I
understand why she's staying by her man
you know and like I'm I want to say that
I would too but then I'm imagining him
just walking out in the hallway like not
like that and like but I'm seeing that
in person I don't know you know what I
like his head got bigger but his body
got smaller so it's like super skinny
and you know all I'm saying is I didn't
know that bodies could do that then it's
it's crazy when you're with someone or
when they're like uh like day-to-day you
don't see how bad it's getting but when
you show the pictures it's like it's
like zero hundred 100 or 200 the 300
back there is a post on Instagram if I
check this off in 3 weeks ago with his
head is like half the size that's so sad
she's a [ __ ] dope as life yeah that's
a ride-or-die I just feel like it should
be banded or something because it looks
like it's exposed they go to go back to
the first signs because but and look
great the first scientist orally what
the what this is this looks the worst
because he still looks human so but then
like okay that's messed up but then like
when he starts to like oh my god looks
like those goldfish with the big eyes
right there she looks happy though look
at her she looks happy they are very
happy and they're so very hopeful for a
miracle he's 21 years old by the way so
he's down
that is crazy are you wait I feel like
you would not stand by Bart if this
happen
me last picture but Jo's killing me
looks like him and then he's posing and
he's happy he has a great attitude
he's having a great time we're the ones
that are having a bad time feeling sorry
for him he's posing live in his best
life he's living his best life his wife
but damn they're not married I go oh I'm
so sorry I just feel like that's wife
behavior I know maybe they're not
married but and like you know she's not
even sticking around for like some kind
of inheritance because like they're not
even married she didn't get anything you
know she's just like dope I feel so
blessed to just have regular health like
to not some crazy ass [ __ ] disease
like oh my god it looks like what we got
a tough man
that's dope that he's still able to mess
around and she's a tough guy cuz if if
that was me I'll be like no just you Lee
you get away from me yeah they're like
death bull Deadpool Deadpool your
Deadpool I'm like Dave Chappelle
remember when he was a blind KKK guy and
a huge why because she's like why
Clayton Bigsby I yeah he's like you he
left his wife because he found out he
was black like if I was like how can you
be with someone like me I'm all you know
like I'm not the doctor
well better well my DA he's left his
girlfriend do you think the region wide
that's what his thing fixes because they
he didn't have he couldn't go to
specialized medicine in America maybe
I'm sure they would have found it yeah
least like save his face he could have
been blind but they could have saved
I've heard of retinoblastoma before I've
definitely heard of it like I've never
seen that but maybe they catch it in the
early stages and then they drain it or
[ __ ] just surgery or take out the
eyes or some oh my goodness lord I hope
he's not in pain also I'm sure what is
what are the symptoms and warning signs
I wanna know I wanna know too I want to
know like if next time my eyes get red I
might go to the doctor what's crazy is
that are happening at the same time like
both eyes were oh yeah they both swelled
up and they looked the same it just
threw me off I didn't think it was gonna
be like that I thought that he would
have lost his eyes I didn't I didn't
think about yeah yeah swelling is crazy
it sucks that like some people do really
really risky beings like a ton of drugs
or do like extreme sports or whatever
and they come out totally fine and then
some people they're just living life and
something happens you get a little cut
and you get a [ __ ] like [ __ ] staff
and it kills you and tells you you gotta
roll around and dirt and get exposed to
a bunch of [ __ ] well notes are Mexican
so we can't do that there's I mean we
you don't have the superior genes I get
it I don't know if we call that superior
genes but maybe it's just oh we're not
sneezing yeah because you guys are
already a virus so you can't oh really
I'm kidding we want me to tell tyka your
uncle said you're a virus
I'm already gonna [ __ ] him up when he's
older so most likely he's gonna [ __ ] me
up
I even texted Bart the other day I
thought he was so cute David no it's
alright every kid he's a Viper God dad
that's just so cute that [ __ ] hi oh shut
the [ __ ] up he's half of you that's the
problem that's the cute part
[ __ ] only this part right here that's
you and the rest is just part about what
a cute little bastard well I googled
retinoblastoma hold on it says it has
few with any symptoms either green light
who everything is [ __ ] flu-like
symptoms I swear it may be notice if a
pupil appears white when light is shined
into the eye sometimes with flash
photography I know you're gonna do any
at home Oh yo I saw that with the baby
yeah that baby got the [ __ ] [ __ ]
saved because the pink no red no
somebody flash my eyes real quick man oh
my god we need to do a tag you have the
lens thing like he does so it already
looks like but it's not in the people
though
yeah it is oh there's so many diseases
that could [ __ ] kill us
man what's going on how am I still alive
and there's just like no symptoms it's
just like oh here you go
well I mean I don't know what they're
reporting here is that the family
revealed that doctors have no treatment
with radiotherapy or chemotherapy but
they'll go ahead it there's no change
but the young man still hopes for a
miracle that they will disappear but
this post is is not to give false hope
to cancer patients
I admire the girl who is standing by her
partner fans say the love that she gives
her boyfriend is the best thing she
can't offer it even cause miracles to
happen that's true that's true lucky cuz
I heard stories where people's counselor
gets away because there's so much love
that they get what is she could be worse
[Laughter]
or maybe maybe maybe it'll get better
I'm hoping it gets better me too did you
say she's the source of the problem what
what I would have she's sneaking around
but they just keep arguing so it makes
it worse yeah oh you heard once they
break up oh that would be crazy do it is
they please can you leave me so I could
heal Oh what if she's just staying with
him like because she's getting a lot of
publicity right now Oh
the third year you know I just playing
devil's advocate girl I just want her to
be like the notebooks yeah or like the
other one though the knock the walk to
remember know which one is the castle
yeah yeah she was gonna die she's there
because your blessings people you know
that's why I think like I know like
certain people they have like this anger
towards other people who don't take care
of themselves because like for example I
have a friend who's lost her brother
yeah I know they she looks at me in
contempt looks she lost her mother to
cancer right and so she has an issue
with a lot of people who find their
solutions just to take their lives
because her mom didn't get a chance to
live like that so she's projecting yeah
she projects a few things to us but it's
kind of true though like if you're born
without any like ailments and then you
kind of just waste your life away
there's a lot of people who want to be
in your position so you know live a good
life
damn I'm I exercise tomorrow and go to
church real talk I need some security
[Music]
you
[Music]